Oh, calm down, in times like these, this is a balloon
vendingmachine.In
the past, they were often placed on the rooftops of supermarkets and in amusement parks.These slow
balloons ca
n't be inflated even faster.Maybe we should increase the speed of the status.
[Music]  Would you like to
spend 10,000 points and
increase your speed by 10?
[Music]
But won't your falling speed slow down?
This is a cardboard vending machine. It's a
handmade cardboard vending machine that was popular among elementary school students in the past.
For example, Hürby was talking about the
huge labyrinth beneath the seaweed in Seiryu Lake.It's quite a
complicated maze.Just
in case, I'll take a picture of it with a security camera.This is fine.I'll combine
it later and see what happens.  It will be useful
[Music] I
landed well, but I don't know what to do next.